volevo e benvenuti a questo nuovo
episodio di come sia video correlati
abbiamo bisogno di un po di contegno in
questo perché perché i vostri commenti
stanno diventando incredibili vostri
consigli per questo episodio mi avete
consigliato la 13 o roba la prima cosa
che dobbiamo trovare oggi è passare da
bob aggiustatutto ai anche signorino
[Musica]
ora siamo su bob la giusta questo sì
combo siamo entrati sul web
l'aggiustatutto già uscire da qua è un
problema perché siamo sul reparto kid
ecco lo aspetta forse è meglio non
partire con un kit sono tutti chi opera
giusta tutto ciò che si ha
salvini l'aggiustatutto ecco se si fosse
chiamato bob avrei fatto web bob
l'aggiustatutto centra galeazzi partiamo
da andrea galeazzi perché non è kid e
perché se io faccio un canale non
chiudermi è più facile poi trovare gli
anni signorino perché uscire dai kings
ciao e vediamo se scafa una roba decente
mio dio veramente difficile devo entrare
nella musica il discorso è che non so
come arrivare alla musica da qua allora
cosa posso trovare per musica quando mi
devo trovare quei correlati che che non
c'entrano niente nirchio una roba
musicale vi prego poi come ha fatto una
canzone le nirchio bruno son qualcosa di
musicale per cortesia sanremo un video
su sanremo l'avete fatto voi usate da
sanremo a iamm signorino e comunque
difficilissimo però almeno siamo sulla
musica
dovrei entrare i trappers non so come ma
deve entrare nei trapper nate come cene
come ci entrò nei truck per chiudili
perché poi non so che cosa ha fatto
young signorino a parte tensione canzoni
tratte italiane tradotte degli space
valley
questi non sono space valley perfetto
quindi a guys perfetto da qua
teoricamente teoricamente si potrebbe
già arrivare a young signorino perché
vabbè trap qualcosa mi consigliera liam
signorino l'ex leader sfera e basta
se ne basta ho trovato dal polo d'archi
polo
aspetta aspetta che adesso aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta adesso siamo in
trend tori
potrebbe già uscire adesso magari c'è
già solo che quella aveva fatto non so
se ne ha fatte altre sicuramente sì non
conosco altro che chi si avvicina di più
a diane signorino fa vj eccolo manova
aspetta non c'è al signorino il titolo
ma come come forse hai ancora segnan
signorino impazzita beh ormai ci sono
tutti ce l'abbiamo fatta raga io volevo
che questa canzone non abbia nel titolo
young signorino a eccola capirla live ce
l'ho fatta basta tutto questo da bob
aggiustatutto ragazzi se non è record
non lo so io comunque andiamo la seconda
la seconda è ancora più difficile questa
era facile in confronto alla seconda ora
no da pietro ha più di pari
[Musica]
non so come potrei arrivare a pilibhit
da pietro pensa si esce subito scoop per
quel che sanno di noce subito più di by
me ne vado se pensa che con perché
teoricamente fanno gameplay quindi non è
difficile l'argomento più o meno è
quello per quanto siano un all opposto
all'altro nel senso che pietro è molto
superiore dall'imponente pietro arrivare
a più di pike e un minimizzato
teoricamente ci vuole un forte però si
sa mai salve figo farlo subito dal primo
video non so quanto possa essere
fattibile prove se becco qualcosa che al
tipo a o amico ho fatto io che ha fatto
anche più di pai attenzione demonio
sarebbe stato figo farlo linkare ha
subito però mi rendo conto è veramente
difficile allora teoricamente d'acqua da
qua abbastanza semplice per quanto i
correlati italiani ti propongono altri
italiani
proviamo a sbucciare sua honey ciò
vedere se da dal gioco di aoni riesca in
qualche modo applicarmici dentro prova
che degli italiani continua continua a
proporsi sempre italiani quindi andare
all'essere un casino pazzesco può però
non c'è scritto più di pane il titolo
deve esserci scritto più di pane il
titolo perché se no non va bene
mannaggia cielo perché ciò però non non
c'è scritto nel titolo porco leone lui
non mettere eccolo
perché guardi brivido quando potresti
giocare al league of legends perché non
sto guardando i video sto giocando a
video correlati signori andiamo da
questa questa questa è veramente la più
complicata di tutto e giuro su dio da
armadillo a una smr di marco toni che
non so perché mi avete proposto sta roba
però facciamo primo video è amazing
armadillo che vorrei anche vedere se
possibile a questo come fa ad avere
un'arma domani come fai ad avere un
armadillo e a casa come e dove si
trovano è un pokémon questo come arriva
da marco toni da un armadillo dov'era
giappone il giappone marco toni giappone
giappone marco toni some è perfetto
adesso devono solo arrivare al giappone
dai miei video ma edizione anche dejan
box e ad esempio ecco qua assaggiare
dolci dal giappone perfetto e siamo già
in giappone manca marco toni
siamo in giappone continua non so se mi
conviene andare giù o cercare di battere
sul punto giapponese teoricamente ci
siamo perché siamo sul trend giappone
dai mark olson esce marchionni adesso mi
ammazzo cioè e dai e allora altra roba
di giappone l'avevo vista prima perché
servono altre cose giapponesi perfetto
blog epico in giappone magari non miur
prossimo vabbè sempre mio ragazzo tutto
giapponese
così ha capito italia verso il giappone
tutto giapponese teoricamente dovrebbe
aver capito mi piace il giappone no ho
capito che mi piace fa vj buono
riuscirvi un video di marco toni stop al
solo roba jap dai raga veramente ho
aperto un sacco di video del giappone
hanno aperti un sacco cifre go e fatevi
un field di falco o klaus e i ghiacchi
dalle un marco tom waits e monia 8 ore e
io la stessa faccia che a marchio in
questo momento
ne ho tante altre molto carine però tra
tutte io direi di fare da freezer a
giuseppe conte
[Musica]
reaser contro in amerciani ok vediamo se
riesco a trova a uscire da dragon ball
sarà già impossibile però giuseppe conte
quindi da fan page
arriviamo a fanpage sky news attenzione
da skynews italy italy italy lockdown ok
perfetto e sto recitando questo video
mentre sono ancora in quarantena
ok quindi non so quando uscirà fuori sto
sfruttando la quarantena mi porta avanti
noe se cercano di capire se la quale si
arriverà fan page che pubblica una roba
ogni tre secondi della quarantena ok
quindi sono per indietro ma forse ciccia
fuori fanpage non a roma lo fa a
giuseppe conte zio aldo giovanni e
giacomo non certo come no
giuseppe conte giuseppe proprio lui ce
la fa lo trova
raga è stata puntata pazzesca fatemi
sapere qua sotto nei commenti cosa posso
cercare nelle processioni di video
correlati è stato veramente
difficilissimo ciliano prossimo episodio
iscritte a creare piuttosto mi piace e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video dei ragazzi
[Musica]